when you're playing the game who do you
enjoy being the best does that make any
sense like when you're when you played
it oh I want to be I want to I'm going
to be Steph Curry because I want to
shoot like Steph tonight or how does
that work anything is I can't shoot was
dead yes to everybody else you can't
what I came I can't even play well he's
terrible in a game with you I see the
hidden list of the timing on my jumper I
can't figure out Moe whose fault is that
his money your focus obviously practice
pregnancy I'm pregnant he's using he's a
30% shooter in my head I'm just ecstatic
just a great feeling to be able to
represent where I come from my team
organization is state of Oklahoma my
friends and family on the game covered
it crosses so many different households
you know around this world and to have
opportunity to do so I'm very grateful
but we're first of all I'm excited every
year to K comes out I think it's one of
the best games out there are
consistently it's great to be a part of
knowing NBA 2k15 how realistic the game
play is but also the graphics I mean
just seeing how we look on the court
it's it's pretty pretty knowing on the
spot on no I mean I love play it's okay
you know this is much as probably any
other you know basketball player you
know so I was fun gaming hair face
everything is pretty much the same
facial expression so it's about the
realest game I've ever seen
I'm the alpha dog when it comes to the
playing 2k virus safely home everybody
play with the pellet we sat there for
you know four hours at a time doing what
we do on TV just dressed a little
differently and you know Shaq would do
his thing and say I know most dominant
pigment history and every day nobody who
got me I wouldn't have to officiate you
know and then you and you just do your
stuff